you found that there was a commonality
in the perspective on the world did you
find there was a common effect you know
did you get the same sort of high by
meditating in this Buddhist manner I
wouldn't say to that extreme or to that
extent
um but I started meditating and I
started having
um moments where I would get something
that would remind me of it and I'll give
you an example like there would be
moments where I'd feel like I would
start kind of vibrating or something or
I would just feel like this this Divine
connection that reminded me of when I
was on the mushroom so it was like these
moments of it but the difference was
like I felt like I had to work for it so
with the mushrooms is that you take this
and you stay there you rest there but
with the Buddhism it was like you're
doing this stuff I'm meditating I'm you
know to get to that place and then try
to stay there